thanks for being here now this russian
president vladimir putin testing the
medal of america and our allies as he
continues to lay the groundwork for the
most telegraphed russian invasion since
the 1940s it's becoming inevitable as
russia is lining up over 100 000 troops
along the ukrainian border but president
vladimir putin is creating a false sense
of urgency for russia acting like he's
the real victim here against ukraine
we are told war war war
we have an impression
that the ukraine government is probably
preparing the third military operation
and warning us beforehand do not get
involved do not defend those people if
you get involved and defend then the new
sanctions will follow
unbelievable is classic soviet
propaganda coming from vladimir putin
act like russia isn't the aggressor and
then then demand the rest of the world
rally behind the oppressed russians the
biden administration obviously disputes
their claims here's jen saki earlier
this week
president putin has his own audience it
is not the united states of america we
don't have aggressive intent with russia
and certainly the aggression we've seen
at the ukrainian border the bellicose
rhetoric has been coming from one side
really but what if anything can this
administration do to stop vladimir
putin's brazen takeover or invasion here
now former cia station chief boxers
contributor
dan hoffman who worked in moscow
full-time uh dan first off what was your
take from that four-hour presser hard to
sum up something like that but what's
your takeaway
well you know vladimir putin is testing
the resolve of the bind administration
he's threatening military aggression
with a hundred thousand troops on the
ukrainian border in an effort to extort
the united states and nato to recognize
russia's fear of influence i listened to
the press conference one of the key
moments for me was when putin said that
of course russia wanted to focus on
their internal issues but they can't
because of this threat from ukraine
putin wants to portray himself as the
only one the only defender of russia the
besieged fortress that the west is
mounting these attacks against him when
nothing could be farther from the truth
the question for us right now uh is
whether the bible administration will
step up with the right kind of policies
to deter russia's aggression they want
to stop nato from expanding they want to
guarantee that ukraine and georgia will
never be in nato they want to go back to
1997 uh when those many of those nations
uh prior to the collapse of the soviet
union were in the warsaw pact in fact
they've been trying to get talks with
the u.s president with barack obama with
george w bush and donald trump to talk
about the
stopping the expansion of nato all three
prior presidents said no this one's
willing to talk is that the good move
well it's giving putin uh the kind of
positive reinforcement that putin wanted
for having ratcheted up the pressure on
ukraine let's be clear here that that
nato was discussing offering georgia and
ukraine membership action plans back at
the budapest summit in 2008 and that is
what spurred vladimir putin into action
against against georgia first with a
hybrid war in the summer of 08 and then
against ukraine in 2014 when he annexed
crimea and attacked in the donbas
that wasn't enough for ukraine because
just earlier this month nato general
secretary stoltenberg was talking about
russia not having a veto over ukraine's
foreign policy including nato membership
well putin wants one
and if we give him that then we will
have done incredibly incredible harm to
ukraine's democracy and that's what
putin wants so this week we're going to
continue to talk you also said something
interesting in that vladimir putin put
100 plus thousand troops on the border
you said that he's just got to pull him
back because he'll make him look bad how
does he save face and how do we get them
not to invade
where is the uh where's the sweet spot
there
that that's the concern he's created a
false sense of urgency with highly
public demands and it is hard to step
back from all that uh honestly this is
reminiscent to me
of of hitler's march on europe i think
putin took a lot of lessons from that he
claims he's defending ethnic russians in
ukraine which was exactly
the logic that hitler used when he took
a piece of czechoslovakia in the
sudetenland
and i think that's going to be the
challenge for the united states and our
nato allies how do we climb down from
all of this
and i think that's where the blind
administration will put a premium on
collection from our intelligence
community what is really going on in the
kremlin what is what are putin's plans
and intentions i'm sure that that the
u.s intelligence community cia in
particular is on high alert on this one
dan true or false one thing has blown up
in his face and that the ukrainians
aren't ready to break they've actually
unified they've gotten stronger and
they've gotten more nationalistic
they're willing to fight i'm not
convinced the russians want dead bodies
they don't want a real fight they would
just like to crush an opponent the
ukrainians are overmatched but they will
fight to the end and that they i think
vladimir putin knows that
i agree with you i think that's the risk
of putin's brinkmanship it also
demonstrates his weakness he's really
concerned that if ukraine joins nato and
the european union that'll bring all
sorts of democratic ideas which is
really what threatens his regime more
than anything to his neighbor and i
think that's what's of concern uh to
vladimir putin and for sure putin
understands and more importantly he
doesn't care about his public opinion
but he does care what his inner circle
thinks he knows he would spill an
inordinate amount of blood and treasure
if he were to fight in ukraine dan
hoffman knows this very well and he's
very uh concerned about it and that
should concern all of us dan hoffman
thanks so much
thank you happy christmas you got it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else